here's an interesting thing I I thought
you know I'm I'm on this journey to get
the most fittest I've ever been by the
end of the year right this is Phase One
basically of the Marvel weight loss in
Japan Cinematic Universe and um it could
be Thanos
I I yeah I like so I started the cycle
84.5 kilograms right what do you think I
was after eight days 750 kilometers 46
000 calories burnt yeah you already know
the answer but what do you think I would
see because Connor told us that weirdly
enough he didn't actually lose as much
weight yeah depends on how much beer you
write because
[ __ ] Dyson one has a beer
[Laughter]
I want to say you got to like maybe like
close to 80 maybe a little bit under
84.5 to 80. yeah yeah seven days I'd say
around 80.
I don't know
[Applause]
this girl's like oh
it's not this there's nothing there's a
probably muscle yeah is it muscle at
first I thought it's because I was
eating a lot every day yeah and I mean a
lot because you have to you have to stay
ahead of the sort of calorie deficit and
recycling because in your [ __ ]
stomach's like a furnace when you're
cycling fan yeah you put food in you're
like hungry minutes later yeah and so I
was eating so much it's like a
preemptive strike on Hunger that's gonna
[ __ ] take you on Hunger yeah and you
have to do this thing called carblading
the night before you eat like a mountain
of cars I think yeah two days ago right
yeah well we did it every day
he was just eating
you were just loading on carbs I've been
prepping for this
you know you have to eat a lot so I
thought maybe that's why yeah I'm two
kilograms heavier eight days what it
turns out was uh your my muscles were
destroyed after this cycle even now you
know yeah I've got a bit of a hobble
when I walk like someone's taking a
hammer to my kneecap or something and
I'm in a lot of pain even now and uh
basically like because I've destroyed my
muscles they get swollen yeah yeah right
I get you get actual swole yeah swallow
in Japan right so my muscles are like
really big and ridiculous and filled
with water and I think that is why I so
it's waterways
I think their muscles really stiff so I
think it's that and I'm going to weigh
myself again three days and pray to God
I've lost some weight I'm gonna be
really [ __ ] depressed I think I got I
look a bit thinner I don't know though
maybe it's my all my head you you
definitely you definitely look bad yeah
yeah that's for sure because you walked
in today and the first thing I noticed
like damn Chris you are you looking good
man looking thinner yeah looking for
looking like 10 more affable man yeah
people made fun of my like big like
Calves they call me mutable yeah they're
pretty [ __ ] massive they do look like
tumorous
they do they do some call it muscle
I've never seen cars that look like that
it looks like someone's like a baseball
bag to look back
I feel fit I do feel fit that's good
that's good that's what's important
what's the next what's up what's phase
two what's phase two phase two yeah it's
uh it's called a Spartan Race and I've
got to run five kilometers up a mountain
in Niger and then do 20 obstacles like
monkey bars and under the barbed wire
and all this [ __ ] oh cool you know and
I'm I think that'll be harder than the
cycle obviously it's it's not a long
endurance thing like the cycle yeah it's
really really intense yeah it's some
pretty sounds like a Navy SEAL training
regimen yeah it kind of is yeah the sort
of guys that I've seen training for it
like yeah they're like Next Level
Fitness I also feel like that's gonna be
harder than the cycle because like the
cycle you're predominantly only losing
you know yeah but with that one it's
like your whole body
10 days
you're doing some training I have been
running and doing various other things I
better start loading on those carbs
like how do you eat like 8 000 calories
a day you just cut like a reasonable
like person just can't eat that many
calories a day yeah like because some
days we were burning like that much I
can do it yeah
I'm convinced this energy alleys are
just garbage I think that and you swear
why are they garbage you just hate jelly
I just think they're just it's just like
oh as the representative character
I I just think they just [ __ ] jelly
like oh just pour like a mountain of
sugar in it and call it a day I mean it
gives you like the energy
that's horrific why is Joe's face like
that what is that
I'm still waiting for my shirt and pants
you've had nothing
Kelly the jelly is good it's good yeah
it's the calories of a rice bowl in
jelly form facts yeah so you can just
squeeze it it's just much easier to
intake because when I'm on like a shoot
for example and I just need like a quick
intake because I missed lunch or
something Jelly's perfect that's that's
the main thing they Market it as energy
jelly but it's mostly just like a get a
meal in you quick yeah yeah you're
bought out by big jelly company
I
sure of all kinds right yeah I don't
know damn yeah it's just the worst way
for Conor to intake anything it's just
like you bring him jelly it's like no no
get that away from me I mean what's this
nonsense about you not like an oranges
oranges of [ __ ]
of course
ganging up thing on me they are just why
not it's so easy what's your least
favorite fruit Chris since we all I
think I like all fruits equal like awful
what's your favorite fruit bananas oh
okay okay good they are they're the best
they're the best they're the best
portion sized fruits what have you got
against oranges I'm convinced you just
go through addiction every morning like
oh I still have a thyroid about today
yes
and it was Aardvark as well which he
used as the example it's the first word
um uh yeah no I just uh I don't think
they taste very good and their texture
is not very good uh but he likes
chocolate oranges yeah we'll talk about
orange is good though
the combination of the flavors bounces
only Terry's chocolate orange yeah
they're very good I gotta say I I I
can't remember what I named as my least
favorite fruit in the [ __ ] fruit
argument that we had but I want to take
it back I think
um I was thinking about it and I'm like
pears does is does anyone actually stand
by pets really yeah they're good they're
not they're nobody's favorite but yeah
but if I'm giving a pair I'll be like
yeah [ __ ] yeah Pearson dishes are great
too oh yeah that's a pair that's good
I mean because Japanese pears and like
the the could be worse though those
pairs are like different in my opinion
like the the yolnashi and the and the
actual like Japanese like round pairs I
feel they're different
what you just said things
the Japanese pair yeah like Nashi yeah
Nashi like noshi pears and like standard
Western pairs I feel different
almost
oh these ones yeah yeah the the round
ones the rounder ones those ones I
prefer it looks like an apple but tastes
like a pear Asian pear yeah I prefer
those over the pear-shaped pears fruit
cakes
episode isn't it yeah
Jesus oh my God my trash tastes Chris
but uh it's cool when you just think
that when you come out from the tour
you'll be like where's Chris gone he's
just say it's me guys enhancement fit
now because after the spotlight and all
the other things like you wanted to bet
me some money so so Chris said that by
the time I'm back from America he'll
have a six pack and I was like I'll put
some money yeah yeah yeah a thousand
dollars let's do it let's bet and he was
like well you know
but I want to make sure we get this
right okay okay the parameter what no
you cannot be like if I got a six pack
of my Fat's in the wings
the Waterway it's the water weight
I uh what what what's the date that I
have to get the six pack Chris it's easy
to turn around yes when I come back
say November
second
November 28th or something then I'll do
it November we'll do 500 quid for
charity for the IDF the Israeli Defense
Force or right if if if if I could do it
you pay 500 to the immune deficiency
Foundation sure if I fail I'll pay five
hundred dollars
check on it on camera right now what's
the date
November 28th you said the day right now
actually when's this episode coming out
it's probably around that time it's
probably around that time it's around
this episode's coming out right now as
we're recording this it is the 8th of
September yes so you have about two and
a half months yeah you have two and a
half months so by the time this episode
comes out it will be very very close to
the deadline dollars whatever you'll be
fine let's make it
because I want to do it in the flesh
right I don't want to be like send you a
photo because I can do it in the flesh
what about I think I'm in Tokyo November
29th Tuesday
okay so you have you have about two
about three months yeah three months
that's not three months yeah it's two
months in like two thirds yeah two
months and like three weeks but what
does this thing yeah like like
how deep does it need to be it has to be
you have to be able to distinguish the
muscles yeah if we can clearly see six
things yeah then that's a six-pack yeah
easy cut okay okay all right there we go
there it is
by the way it's a win for IDF